[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be Googling Harry Potter
and answering 50 of the top Harry Potter
questions that Google users have fed
into the search engine I expect a lot of
these will be fairly straightforward but
you never know in order to hit the 50
I'll be asking Google what why how where
and when type questions there are a
couple duplicates but I want to stay
true to the format as Google lists 10
for each search anyway without further
Ado let's dive in what did Harry Potter
name his kids Harry had three kids with
his wife Jenny Alber seus Potter James
Sirius Potter and Lily Luna Potter still
not sure why none of them were named
after hrid but that's another video
do for a living after defeating
Voldemort Harry never returned to
Hogwarts to finish his magical education
and nor did Ron he did however begin
working in the aura office at the
ministry of magic he also went on to
become head of the aura Department
parents do for work James and Lenley
died relatively young and so they
weren't really able to establish
themselves in their careers their
attention was needed elsewhere as
Voldemort was active tyrannizing the
wisting world after their graduation
from Hogwarts because of this both of
them were full-time members of the Order
of the
Phoenix get for Christmas Harry got a
lot of different gifts over the years
with many of them handed over to him at
Christmas time here's a complete list of
gifts Harry received some good some
questionable from the desley he got a
toothpick a single tissue and 50p from
Creature he got a package of maggots
from Ron he got dung bombs birti Bots
every flavor beans and a copy of flying
with cannons from Hagrid he got a furry
fanged wallet trickle fudge a vast box
of sweets and a wooden flute from ha he
got chocolate frogs a homework planner
an eagle feather quill and a copy of
Quidditch teams of Britain and Ireland
from Dobby he got a painting made by
Dobby himself as well as some socks from
ton he got a small Firebolt model broom
from the Weasley twins he got a big box
of items from their shop Weasley's
wizard wheezers from Arthur and Molly he
got a jumper and sweets every year from
Sirius he got a pen knife and a Firebolt
from Remis and Sirus he got a copy of
practical defensive magic and its use
against the dark arts and last but not
least Harry was gifted the fabled
invisibility cloak by Dumbledore an item
that had been left in Dumbledore's
possession by Harry's
father doe after Hog quarts like I
mentioned above Harry went on to marry
jinny Weasley have three children and
serve as head of the aura department for
the ministry of magic name his son his
two sons were Alber seus and James
Sirius do what didn't he do say to the
snake this question of course refers to
the snake that appears near the
beginning of philosopher stone in the
books he says leave him alone and in the
films he just says leave him look like
in the books Harry had always been small
and skinny for his age Harry had a thin
face knobbly knees black hair and bright
green eyes he wore round glasses held
together with a lot of cell tape because
of all of the times dle had punched him
in the nose become he became a father
and working member of
society why did Harry Potter not die
because of the next question I'm going
to answer this question in reference to
Harry dying in the Forbidden Forest
Harry is able to return and doesn't
properly die for two reasons the first
is that Voldemort simply killed the
piece of his own soul inside of Harry
and not Harry himself for this reason
Harry is given the choice to return to
the land of the living the second reason
that Harry didn't die is that Voldemort
still lived with Harry's blood in his
veins we see one of the crucial
ingredients in Voldemort's regeneration
potion was blind of an enemy Q Harry not
die as a baby Harry Potter survived as a
baby because his mother's sacrificial
love created a powerful protection that
rebounded Voldemort's killing curse this
sacrificial protection kept Harry alive
and made it impossible for Voldemort to
harm him directly without suffering
intense pain drop the resurrection Stone
Harry Potter dropped the resurrection
Stone because he understood that it was
not meant to be used to bring back the
dead he recognized that accepting death
and moving forward was necessary for his
own journey and the greater good become
so popular because it's awesome change
directors in total there were four
directors who helmed the Harry Potter
film series Chris Columbus directed
Harry Potter in the philosopher stone
and Harry Potter in the Chamber of
Secrets Alonso coron directed Harry
Potter in the prisoner of aaban Mike nle
directed Harry Potter in the gobl of
fire and David Yates directed films 5
through 8 Changers have direct were due
to creative differences personal reasons
and consistency in the running theme
personally I'm a fan of how the films
evolved gradually getting darker and
adopting different styles break the
Elder Wand first of all Harry only
breaks the Elder Wand in the film in the
books it's laid to rest with Dumbledore
second of all Harry broke the Elder Wand
in the films because he understood its
immense power and the potential danger
it posed in the wrong hands he did not
want the the wand to become a tool of
Temptation or be sought after by evil
wizards breaking it ensure that its
power would be lost and because the
story has to end somewhere though I am
excited to see what's done with the
upcoming Harry Potter HBO series come
back to life already answered this his
parents die Harry's parents died because
they were in the way of Voldemort's
quest for power a prophecy was made that
stated that a child born at the end of
July who had parents that had defied
Voldemort three times would have the
power to defeat him Voldemort believed
Harry Potter was the child in the
prophecy and sought to eliminate him but
James and ly sacrificed themselves to
protect their son destroy the Elder one
because he's a fool when did Harry
Potter books come out the very first
Harry Potter book in this series was
published in the UK on June 26th 1997
with the release of Harry Potter and the
philosopher stone from there the series
series continued with the release of a
new book every year to year and a half
thereafter concluding with Harry Potter
and the death of the Hallows in
2007 come out since I've already
answered this for the books Let's go
with the films the Harry Potter films
were released between 2001 and
2011 the series consists of eight movies
starting with Harry Potter and the
philosopher stone in 2001 and concluding
with Harry Potter and the death the
allers part two in 2011 fun fact I went
to see see all of these in theaters did
you become popular Harry Potter has been
popular pretty much since the release of
the very first book in
1997 the books quickly gained immense
popularity worldwide receiving extremely
positive reviews and attracting a wide
audience of both adults and young
readers movies come out 2001 through
2011 take place the events of the Harry
Potter series and Harry's Adventures
take place predominantly between 199 91
and
1998 however JK Rawlings Wizarding World
law dates back Centuries with Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry being
established around the 10th Century one
come out book 1997 film
2001 go to Hogwarts Harry first went to
Hogwarts in
1991 this is when he received its
acceptance letter and began his magical
education at the age of 11 first come
out 1997 book and 2001 film two come out
ah Chamber of Secrets 1998 for the book
and 2002 for the film's parents die
Harry's parents Lily and James Potter
died on October 31st
1981 they were killed by Lord Voldemort
during his attempt to kill Harry their
infant son where did Harry Potter live
this question depends on the time period
first of all Harry lived with his
parents in godric's Hollow following
that Harry lived with his aunt Uncle and
Cousin at number four privet Drive
during this time period he also lived in
the Gryffindor dormit Tre at Hogwarts
following that he lived at the burrow
the Weasley family home following that
he lived at number 12 grimel place a
home he inherited from his Godfather
Sirius Black and lastly Harry found
himself living in a flat above his
workplace in Diagon Alley take place
this is a massively open-ended question
where didn't it take place is this an in
universe or out of universe question the
primary setting of Harry Potter is
Hogwart School of Witchcraft and wiid
located in the Scottish Highlands other
significant locations would be Diagon
Alle hogsmeade number four privet drive
and a few other magical and non-magical
places within the UK get The Shard of
mirror Harry Got The Shard of mirror
from Sirus Black in Harry Potter in the
Order of the Phoenix just before
returning to Hogwarts after the
Christmas holidays Sirius gave him one
of the two-way mirrors grew up mainly
number four Private Drive and
Hogwarts get his money Harry inherited
all of his riches from a long line of
successful family members including
lfred of ccom and font Potter lenford
was a successful potioneer and creator
of both skelo and peup potion and femont
was responsible for the creation of
sleek E's hair potion the Potter family
fortune was eventually passed down to
James and after his death it was left
with Harry film Harry Potter was filmed
in many different locations including
the University of Oxford darham
Cathedral olnick castle and gluster
Cathedral among many other places live
after Hogwarts Harry lived in a flat in
Dagon alley with his wife and kids live
before Hogwarts Harry lived with the
dersley before Hogwarts a number four
privet Drive
sleep in the dery's house initially
Harry slept in a Cupboard Under the
Stairs however he was eventually given
Dudley's old room money come from Harry
had vast generational wealth trust fund
Potter how did Harry Potter not die
adult Tethered to Life by his blood in
Voldemort's veins child protected by
Lily's sacrificial protection come back
to life oh come on get his scar Harry
got his scar as a result of Voldemort's
failed killing curse when he was a baby
the scar is on the right side of his
forehead and is a symbol of his
connection to the dark wizard parents
die they were murdered by Voldemort and
sacrificed themselves to save Harry
survive powerful ancient magic
sacrificial protection die Harry Potter
died when he was shoted by Voldemort's
killing curse in the Forbidden Forest
willingly sacrificing himself however
this was not a true death end Harry
Potter's journey and the story concludes
with the defeat of Lord Voldemort during
the Battle of Hogwarts he survives and
ultimately defeats Voldemort restoring
peace to The Wizarding World not die as
a baby oh not again kill Voldemort the
first time Harry kills Voldemort is when
he's just a baby because Lily had placed
a loving sacrifice on Harry he was
impervious to Voldemort's attacks and
one of Voldemort's killing blows fired
back at him the second time Harry kills
Voldemort once and for all I might add
is when he defeats him during the Battle
of Hogwarts in the Battle of Hogwarts
Harry Potter kills Voldemort by using
expelis which causes Voldemort's killing
curse of arak kadavra to backfire and
ultimately destroy him however the Elder
one plays a significant role in this
encounter prior to the Battle of
Hogwarts Voldemort had stolen the Elder
oneand from dore's tomb believing it
would make him Invincible unbeknownst to
vold Mor Harry disarmed Jericho Malfoy
who was the true Master of the Elder
Wand at that point thus Harry becomes a
new master of the wand when Harry and
Voldemort spells Clash during their
Final Duel the power of the Elder Wand
recognizes its true master and turns
against Voldemort causing his own
killing curse to rebound and result in
his
downfall get down the hill walking JK
rolling get it I'm sorry and that's it
for this video what other Harry Potter
questions do you guys have please let me
know down in the comment section below
also if you enjoyed the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live